[Music]
hey everybody its charlie so I got a lot
of requests to do a video for umbrella
Academy so I'll explain the ending and
there's a lot of x-men Easter eggs
because a lot of this is spun out up
like a very misfit version of the x-men
the story of season 1 also largely
parallels the Dark Phoenix storyline
from the x-men comics which is funny
because we have x-men Dark Phoenix with
sophie turner coming out later this year
bringing it all back around for Kitty
Pryde Ellen Page if you're brand new to
my channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos in obviously spoiler
warning for umbrella academy season 1
because we'll be talking about all the
really specific plot beats and Easter
eggs so at the end of the season they've
discovered that Vanya number 7 has
powers whereas she kind of grew up is
the Meg of the family like Family Guy
meg always treated as a second-class
citizen they always dumped on her the
brothers and sisters didn't know because
their father hid it from them you learn
in the flashbacks that because her
father was so afraid of how much power
she had she's like the Dark Phoenix of
the family he's sort of giving her pills
quote-unquote to help her that suppress
her powers and she sort of had this
mental block that just made her forget
did she ever had them so that's why as
an adult she has no memory of ever being
that powerful the other critical piece
of this that pushes her over the edge
is Harold Peabody who turns out to
really be Harold Jenkins someone who was
born at the same time as all these other
Medes by coincidence but he was just
born a normal person his mother died in
childbirth
his father became this abusive alcoholic
so because he felt like he had a
connection to all these Medes like oh I
was born at the same time maybe I
secretly have powers too he became sort
of a syndrome type person when they
laughed him out of the Academy so they
treated him a little bit like they
treated Vanya aka like Meg from Family
Guy so he felt a kinship to her like hey
you're just like me you're an outsider
then he learned her secret when he got
those journals then because he was part
of the original timeline he just wanted
to destroy the Academy he wasn't about
destroying the world that was all
because of the second timeline so his
whole plan was to get rid of all of her
brothers and sister that was it but then
of course as you saw things went
completely off the rails when she kills
him the story of season 1 is like this
very identifiable x-men style story
where you have an outsider that's driven
away by the actions of the
family they realized that then try to
help her and bring her back into the
fold so that they can heal and deal with
all their dysfunction pretty standard
fare for an x-men style story that is
essentially the story of x-men Dark
Phoenix Jean Grey being manipulated by
outside forces being driven away from
the group the x-men not dealing with it
a whole bunch of people are dying as a
result of all these mistakes then
umbrella academy his big departure from
that story is the big time-travel twist
at the end of this time travel also a
really big mechanic of the season
because it's number 5 that learns about
the apocalypse and tries to do things to
avoid it but the big antagonists that
you saw chacha and her partner are
working for those are the temps they're
basically like time cops although
they're a little bit sinister because
they were trying to preserve the
apocalypse no matter what happened they
would always try to bring it about in a
different way which is why their boss
said no matter what you do you must
protect Vanya now but because at
different points in the season because
number 5 was changing the timeline the
way the apocalypse hapten changed the
temps were trying to stay one step
behind him to ensure that no matter what
those changes worked that they would
still get that apocalypse when number 5
jumps forward and sees the first version
of the apocalypse in the original
timeline he just finds the mansion in a
pile of rubble and all the team members
are dead so then he goes back they
change things they still get the
apocalypse but this time they caused the
apocalypse because they try to kill
Vanya so that's actually really
important idea maybe like trying to kill
Jean Grey to stop the Phoenix force the
Phoenix force would just jump into
someone else's body and you'd be no
better off than you were before
and you would have killed a family
member so the lesson here as they
realize like they're all standing here
like no we have a better idea we're
gonna try and jump back in time and fix
her like the present-day version of
Vanya so that this never happens in the
future so if it wasn't clear when
they're going around the circle and they
look like they're turning young that's
more of a subconscious thing like
they're going back to the beginning
there being a family again like they
were not during the first timeline so
when they show up again during season 2
they will still be adults but the plot
will turn a lot more on time travel with
them jumping around trying to change the
timeline and the whole idea being that
you know ultimately no matter which
adventures that they have and how many
different things that they do will this
moment still wind up happening at the
end of the series sort of like the flash
future newspaper we try
to make a whole bunch of changes to the
timeline through five six seven seasons
of the show will this moment still
happen no matter what we change so even
though it seems like cha cha dies in
that giant explosion remember they're
going back in time they're gonna change
the timeline again meaning that when
they go back the Temps agency that's
after them will still be around they'll
still be an antagonist but if you
haven't read the comic book there is a
volume two they did Volume one for the
story of season one so it stands the
reason they could do volume two for
season two or they could jump forward
and do season three or they could
combine a couple of comic book
storylines the other really big villain
that they could bring forward is dr.
Terminal and he does appear a little bit
during volume 1 but he's a much bigger
character during volume 3 volume 2 of
the comic is just called Dallas and it
mostly revolves around number 5 the Time
Traveler's involvement in the Kennedy
assassination it trades on a lot of
tropes of American history it's very
time-travel heavy like at one point
they're fighting this giant statue of
Abraham Lincoln that's brought to life
but because you're jumping around in
time you do get to bring back Reginald
Hargreaves so even though he's dead in
present day he is a big part of volume 2
volume 3 is called Hotel oblivion and
that's sort of like this otherworldly
prisoned that Reginald Hargreaves
created to put dr terminal in and he
vows to come back and destroy the world
so later in the comic series he goes
from being a villain to being a really
big super villain they could bring him
forward towards the end of season two I
don't know exactly what their plan is
gonna be but overall I thought they did
a good job of adapting volume one of the
comic book it's called the apocalypse
suite in the apocalypse suite is the
music that she's playing at the end
where she's causing the apocalypse so
that's why the violin is so important
for our ability if you're not really
sure how her ability works she just has
the ability to turn sound waves into
pure energy which is why the violin is
her main weapon so that's what's
happening when she's immobilizing them
with that white lightning in the second
reason why they caused the apocalypse
when she gets shot by her sister and it
causes her to misfire in this giant
bolts of energy shoots and hits the moon
causing it to break apart and that just
sort of compounds the problem but again
the message is very clear you work
together as a family
heal the dysfunction try to fix her get
her the mental help that she needs so
that she can be a productive member of
the group and they can go on fighting
whatever and
next threat comes along together the
funny thing too is they almost did this
exact same plot on the flash TV show in
this week's episode where Nora has the
ability to rewind time and she just
keeps doing it over and over again
trying to figure out a way out of her
situation but just like umbrella Academy
she realizes you can't do this alone you
have to come together as a group to do
things together everyone is more
powerful together than apart so that'll
probably be a theme going into season 2
where they'll be an even bigger threat a
la doctor terminal or if they want to
turn the temps agency into a much bigger
thing because some of those characters
are actually pretty interesting if
you're a big fan of Gerard ways comic
book then you also probably got a lot of
Doom Patrol vibes because he's also been
writing Doom Patrol they're very much a
team of misfits in the vein of umbrella
academy so they largely inspired the
Umbrella Academy comic book but also
very dysfunctional version of the x-men
group a really messed up kids trying to
be a family together dealing with all
their problems they went way over the
top though because it's Netflix and you
can do anything you want there's no kind
of censorship issues so obviously they
tried to have a lot of fun with that
idea like this isn't something that you
would see on network television but I
thought the effects were great in the
talking chimp Pogo he was great too like
sometimes you just don't know until you
actually see it but whatever special
effects they used to create his
performance whether it was a practical
suit or whether it was motion capture
like Rocket Raccoon and all the
guardians of the galaxy in the Avengers
movies but as for an actual season two
they haven't made any announcements yet
there hasn't been any official teasers
or anything so if you have any big
questions about the series or where
things are headed just leave them in the
comments below
Netflix has a lot of really cool stuff
coming later this year they have The
Witcher TV series I don't think we're
gonna get a trailer for that for a while
though but I will do videos for The
Witcher when it gets here just because
it is sort of my meal you because I do
so much Game of Thrones the Lord of the
Rings and all that big fantasy stuff so
while you wait for everything click here
for my brand new Avengers infinity war
trailer video and click here for my
brand new Game of Thrones Season 8 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]